hi everyone
welcome I'm Triana Trojan I am the
director of the Frankie program in
science and humanities at Yale and also
an astrophysicist with appointments in
the physics and astronomy departments so
mapping has been a subject that has
informed my scientific work and has been
a theme that many of us in astronomy of
course have eternally been involved in
but over the last few decades mapping
has been used both as a metaphor and for
literally mapping things that we see and
know so inspired by sort of the changing
definition of mapping we in the Frankie
program decided to focus on trying to
understand contextually what mapping
means today across disciplines and as
part of that we started this new series
called mapping as knowing and we have
invited several scientists artists
writers thinkers we have a program
that's unfolding over the entire
academic year addressing this issue of
what maps teach us what they encode what
their limits are and what are the new
ways in which we can push maps and
learning from maps so it is with great
pleasure today that I would like to
introduce our speaker in the series dr.
Eric Sanderson he's the third speaker in
this series and to just give you a very
brief recap of the trajectory the arc of
how we have been tackling mapping so far
we started off with Professor Matthew
Edney who is very eminent cartographer
who drew attention to the limits of what
mapping can do and what are what is
encoded in maps that actually limits our
understand it encodes how we think at
any particular time but that also
imposes mental limits on what can be
mapped at a given time so if you look at
colonial maps versus maps today of the
same terrain so if you look at
cartographic map they import very
different things and the second speaker
in our series was dr filiz Frankel who
talked about the purposes Maps actually
serve in science and engineering today
they serve not just as tools of
visualization but as avenues for
innovation
so keeping with sort of these this
roaming theme of mapping today we have
dr. Sanderson who will be talking to us
about mapping time and space together in
this fantastic visionary project that
he's been leading for several decades
now which has been mapping the past
present and future of nature in New York
City so this kind of conflict if you
will or conversation between ecology and
urbanism over time and how that's played
out in this sort of one piece of coveted
real estate in the world but before I
tell you more about him I want to thank
Richard and Barbara Frankie who have
generously supported the program and are
supporting this series and I'm
absolutely delighted to see Richard here
in the audience this evening so first
and before I forget we have a fabulous
reception outside in room 108 following
following the talk so please do stay for
that so Eric Sanderson is a senior
conservation ecologist at the Wildlife
Conservation Society his PhD is an
ecology with a particular focus on
ecosystem and landscape ecology from the
University of california-davis and
starting at the Wildlife Conservation
Society in 1998 he has established the
landscape ecology and geographic
analysis program to bring luck landscape
thinking and geographic analysis tools
into the conservation practices in 2002
dr. Sanderson and his colleagues created
the human footprint map the first look
at human influence globally at less than
one square mile resolution I highly
recommend your going to his web page and
looking at some of the wonderful visual
material that he and his colleagues have
been creating he's also an expert on
species conservation planning and has
contributed to efforts to save lions
tigers Asian bears Jaguars two pairs and
peccaries American crocodiles North
American bison and it goes on and on and
landscape planning conservation efforts
across the world in Argentina Tanzania
Mongolia and the Greater Yellowstone
Ecosystem closer to home and the
Adirondack Park and on the East Coast he
has edited to scientific volumes and
written numerous scientific papers his
work is amply featured in the media and
I would be surprised if you haven't
actually come across him or his work in
the New York Times National Geographic
magazine CNN or The New Yorker he is
also the director of this wonderful
project that we are going to be learning
about today the manhatta project which
is an effort to reconstruct the original
ecology of Manhattan Island starting
from the time of European discovery in
the early 17th century to today so in
2009 he published this wonderful book
called manhatta
a natural history of New York City of
which I have this copy here highly
recommend that you get it has really
beautiful illustrations and it's he
curated an exhibition based on this
project and which is on display at the
Museum of the city of New York and he
also as I mentioned earlier
has this website that allows the users
it's a very wonderful user-friendly
website where you can navigate and learn
and actually look at the transformation
of the landscape so without further ado
I would like to invite dr. Sanderson
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you so much for you thank you for
that wonderful introduction and thank
you all for coming out in such a dreary
afternoon to hear a story about about
mapping and I kind of hope that maybe
there's three three aspects that I can
contribute to this this seminar series
about mapping what one is is as the
title says this way of thinking about
how nature and one particular place one
particular place that matters to a lot
of us New York City how that has changed
over time and how it might change into
the future the second thing I hope
you'll take out of this is the ways that
maps are really go beyond a physical
piece of paper with lines and colors on
it but not to all the different ways
that we think of mapping today and all
the ways we can use technology and to
map and see our world and then the third
part is the sort of personal story for
me of how maps maps are a really
important part of my life and I think it
really comes out in this in this process
and they've been a huge and valuable way
for me to sort of conceptualize and see
my role in New York City's nature so
that more I do I want to take you to
this place this is Manhattan Island and
I would like you to imagine if we can go
into a time machine and go back 400
years to when Henry Hudson was first
sailing into New York Harbor what might
we have seen and we might have seen
something like this I hope you can make
that out this is a rendering of
Manhattan Island on September 12 1609
about two o'clock in the afternoon
there's a little shift and we can see
the ship in the Hudson River there
that's Henry Hudson ship the half moon
through our research we've come to
understand that this this island had 54
different ecosystem types 54 different
illogical communities maybe a thousand
different species were living there
including people they've been people
living in a New York City region for
about 8,000 years and I don't you can
see the smoke rising from one of their
settlements down in lower Manhattan
along the collec pond so this isn't uh
unpeopled wilderness this is a place
where people been living for a long
and enjoying the landscape for the
LaMotte pay people were the most recent
culture for me two and a half times long
as European people have been there and
they called this place mana hata or the
island of Minnie Hills we finished our
work on mana hata in 2009 when this book
was published and subsequently been
working on the rest of the city I won't
talk about this so much tonight but I
just wanted to mention if you ever see
we look here if you go to our website
you'll hear this term it's another
little op a word and it means my good
home and that's exactly how we want
people to see this environment is a
really good place for people to live
because nature has made it so and then
finally toward the end of my
presentation I'm going to talk a little
bit about a new platform that we've
constructed based on the historical
ecology that allows anyone in New York
City to dream and imagine and construct
and evaluate the future of their
neighborhood called vision maker NYC so
my story has five acts and the first
part is about a map found I don't know
if you can tell from the way I speak but
I'm not from New York originally I grew
up in Northern California and when I was
a young person I wanted to do nothing
more than to be in the mountains and I
took this picture on the left actually
when I was on the John Muir Trail when I
was about 14 years old and this way of
seeing nature is something composed of
ecosystems is what eventually led me to
pursue a set of graduate studies in a
field called landscape ecology and -
landscape ecologist we look at a picture
like that and we see different kinds of
ecosystems in a configuration with each
other we see this dream beside the
meadow and the meadow beside the forest
and the forest beside that cliff in the
distance you know as if we were a bird
flying over the meadow and we think
about how does that composition of
ecosystems and that configuration make
habitat for plants and animals including
for people you know most creatures live
at the landscape scale as we talked
about and landscape ecology is help we
understand how those landscape patterns
are made and how they're changing over
time and once you sort of get that idea
in your head that any landscape has
these ecosystems and they have it
changement to them like pieces of a
puzzle then you can start to see that
you know everywhere you see this and in
canyon de chelly in Arizona for example
you see that
shrublands on the side of the on the
side of the hills the cliffs and the
valley and the bottom and much to my
surprise knowing about this company a
job at the Bronx Zoo at the Wildlife
Conservation Society 20 years ago this
year actually and part of the reason why
I agreed to take my career into
conservation and and typically in
conservation in New York City where I
wasn't from is because this place was
founded by these conservationists of a
previous generation like Teddy Roosevelt
they're on the steps of the Bronx Zoo
administration building you know Teddy
Roosevelt helped save those places help
conserve those landscapes in California
that I grew up loving so much and so I
thought well maybe I can walk in his
footsteps and then much to my surprise
they gave me a office in this building
so I was literally walking up these
steps every morning going to work
thinking about Teddy Roosevelt but
whereas my work is through the zoo and
through the Wildlife Conservation
Society and isn't actually about the
animals in the zoo but actually I was
hired to help WCS think at the landscape
scale all over the world whether it's
for Jaguars or rhinos or spectacled
bears in Latin America and so I was I
had this sort of itinerant existence for
the first five or six years I was with
WCS flying all over the world going to
extremely wild places seeing really
extraordinary people doing some really
interesting things and then flying back
to New York and this is a this is a
picture from that first summer in 1998
that I was in New York City from the top
of the Empire State Building and I was
you know trying to figure out what am i
doing either you know what is Eric the
Californian you know the person
committed to wild places doing and
arguably the most influenced place the
most dramatically changed place in the
world and can the ideas that you know
that I talked about all the time
landscape ecology can have actually
applied to a city can we actually see
those buildings as a kind of ecosystems
as the streets as a kind of ecosystem as
the part
can the river in the distance is part of
that landscape configuration and how
does that pattern make habitat for
plants and animals including for people
you know how did it how did it come to
be I mean it's I think it's hard to walk
around in midtown Manhattan and not be
sort of overwhelmed by the sheer
monumentality of the place something
else that struck me when I moved to York
is is how much New Yorkers talk about
the future and are disconnected from
their past which is to say that people
come you know a lot of people come to
New York because they want to make a new
life for themselves or or for the world
you know that that's in business or in
media or the arts or even in the
sciences and there's all these kind of
odd weird things about New York City
that don't make any sense it cept in
their historical context so this is
another one of those snapshots this
isn't Times Square and you know I was
taking a picture of the of the
advertising on the wall but who's that
guy standing on the statue there what's
father Duffy you know really important
there's a priest he worked in Times
Square in the late 19th early 20th
century they want to have Times Square
as we do and without father Duffy and
he's right there in the middle of Times
Square and nobody ever remembers him
right it's this this odd thing about New
York which is so different than other
great cities around the world if you go
to London or Paris or Tokyo or you know
Delhi you know you feel as part of this
sort of long tradition of people you
know that there been people there before
you that created that landscape and
there gonna be people after you and
you're sort of part of this historical
tradition in a way that New York City
just doesn't have that sense of itself
which course is an opportunity because
the the signs of that old history are
everywhere around us these rock outcrops
in Central Park here are Precambrian era
rock formations the part of the original
North America kraton they're a billion
years old they're older than life on
Earth right
or if you see I know if you can see a
little bit of the topography here in
Central Park you know that's the
original topography modified some by
Olmsted and Vaux but the original
topography of the island of many Hills
and then if you think of those buildings
south of 59th Street
as a kind of hell well the islands way
Hillier now than it ever was 400 years
ago one of hims I do when I come to a
new place and I want to learn about as I
read its history and I read the New York
City was the first mega city on the face
of the planet a city of of 10 million
people or more up until 1950 there had
never been such a thing a place that
ancient Rome not London in the 19th
century New York City in 1950 was the
only place in the world with ten million
people were living in one one locality
today there's between 25 and 30 mega
cities as we count there might be 50 you
know by the middle of the century
urbanization has been such an enormous
way of transforming human society over
the courses of our lifetimes and over
the courses of the lifetime of our to
our children so it just struck me that
that New York's experience as a mega
city so early on that the pains and and
the pleasures of enormous density are a
really important story to tell but to
get to that story we have to sort of see
through it to the landscape that was
there before and you know I'd be reading
these history books and then they'd have
like a little black and white picture
you know or I like that's where I saw
this this image for the first time
does anybody know this place this is um
if you know New York at all this is um
125th Street underneath the West Side
Highway where the fairway market is you
know if you're going down to see your
friends at Columbia University you might
get off the highway here
well there's to be a beach there this
painting is by Victor different Audubon
John James Audubon's son it's from 1841
that's them John James sitting on the
rock here watching the men bring in the
fish from Ladson River and we're looking
to the north up Washington Heights that
wooded eminence in that point of land
you see there that's Jeffries hook where
the George Washington Bridge goes across
to the Palisades today and I thought you
know and all the thousands of things
that are written about New York City
every year how come nobody ever mentions
the beach we used to be there or the
forests or you know the way the land
juts out there and how come we've
forgotten this part
our history if we go back a little
further this is an engraving from the
1760s so before before the you know
before the foundation in the United
States these are two students from
King's College you know now Columbia
University they're sitting on a hill
overlooking a valley in Soho right and I
would literally go on my weekends and
look for that hill and I can tell you
it's not there I walk all over Soho and
you will not see that hill nor that
valley nor that palm tree that palm tree
and for years I wondered about that palm
tree and then I read a little account of
Davies the man who made this he was an
engraver and he apparently he sent his
drawing back to London to be engraved in
the 1760s and the engraver thought you
know this composition needs a vertical
element and so he had it a palm tree
because it's from America right because
America's you know a place for palm
trees it was in the it was in the midst
of this sort of you know trying to
figure out what I was doing in New York
City then I was in the Strand on 12th
Street downtown and I was thumbing
through some of their own New York City
books and there's great book called
Manhattan in maps that have been
published the year before I came in the
city in 1997 and it's a map of it's a
book of maps that aren't very well known
about the city and it was in that map
that I saw or in that book that I saw
this map which is the British
headquarters map from 1780 to 1783 made
by British military cartographers during
the war for military planning purposes
this is the kind of thing that
frustrating might have shown you it's
showing you I'm showing you Manhattan on
its side so that's those sort of pink
blocks over there that's the city in the
1780s and if you look carefully you can
see the bowling bowling green the sort
of green circle and then it says Ted of
New York that's Broadway and then
there's a little pink triangle there
that's City Hall Park so the entire city
was basically Bowling Green is City Hall
Park about a 20-minute walk during the
American Revolution but what's north of
that is what got my attention that pond
that that lake in lower Manhattan the
marshes beside it all these hills all
these streams what are all these streams
doing you know this was map for military
planning purposes you know like where to
deploy your cannon where to send your
soldiers you know this sort of thing but
as an ecologist I was like oh oh you
know I'm seeing these fundamental
aspects of the landscape right the
hydrology the shoreline you know the
some sense of the ecosystems the salt
marshes and the freshwater marshes and
the map goes all the way up the island
you know Central Park the Harlem Plains
the 123 Street gap that Beach I just
showed you all the way up to northern
Manhattan and a few years later I
actually went to England and went to the
National Archives and after a big hubbub
Lou got in and turning my little slip of
paper and they brought me the British
headquarters map which is 10 feet long
and three and a half feet wide six
inches to a mile scale a really
extraordinary document a really
beautiful beautiful map and and so the
first thing I said to them is making a
scan of this map we take a picture of
this map because if I can take a picture
of this map then I can pull it into my
geographic information system which is a
technology for for managing and mapping
and taking care of data about maps and I
can georeference it to the modern city
grid I can actually relate these
features were seeing on the British
headquarters map to their modern
location when Nick pop garden wrote
about this in The New Yorker he said
this is sort of a naturalist version of
George Washington slept here right like
oh there's a stream under my building oh
I guess that's why the basement plugs
every winter oh you know I'm my house is
in a salt marsh Oh Hurricane sandy
that's why we have you know six feet of
water on the first floor you know that
sort of thing and moreover by geo
referencing the map and then carefully
tracing the features and then doing
research to fill in what you know what
we could figure out about what was
before the British headquarters map we
can make maps of the streams of
Manhattan and the topography the five
hundred
seventy-three Hills and the 21 oil types
and these allowed us to reconstruct a
new vision of home so you know one of
the things I love about Yale is there
was an important ecologist who an
english ecologist who worked here in the
50s and he wrote a great book a little
short book called them the ecological
play and the evolutionary stage and that
idea is a fundamental idea to call in
landscape ecology which is to say that
there are these physical factors about
the landscape which are the stage that
they're created by geological forces by
geographic forces by climatological
forces even arguably by astronomical
forces geology topography the water
courses the shoreline land cover and
that these allow us to derive a sense of
the stage on which nature is going to
play out its drama and that drama is
driven by disturbances by factors by
catastrophes things that reduce the
biomass in the structure of ecosystems
things like fires and floods and land
use and hunting wind throws and that if
you know the combination of the stage
and the drama the disturbances that you
can start to make predictions about
where the ecosystems were that this
combination of fire and floods and
watersheds of this slope and and this
soil condition lead to a mid reap stream
or a high salt marsh or a chestnut oak
forest or all of the 54 different
ecosystem types I wrote a paper in the
2000 with a graduate student sort of
marveling that there were so many
different ecosystem types on Manhattan
you know that that to come out of just
putting these relationships together 54
different ecosystem types on Manhattan
if you compare it to the vegetation map
of Yellowstone National Park Yellowstone
National Park has 63 types and a 2.2
million acres Manhattan is 1/10 of 1%
and it has 54 types and you don't have
to be much ecologist to know that if you
have a diversity of different ecosystem
types you're gonna have a wide diversity
of different species so that led to a
sort of sort of sub hobby of this larger
hobby that I had which was going to see
these
ecosystems most of which still exist
around New York City in parks and
preserves if you know where to go look
that we could go to that I could go to
the hemlock northern hardwood forest in
Orange County and that would be like
what the northern part of Murray Hill
might have looked like four hundred
years ago or I could go visit the last
little fragment of the Hempstead Plains
grassland on Long Island this is what
Harlem might have looked like or see a
coastal plain pond and see this is what
the collect on in lower Manhattan or
this is what the Upper West Side might
have looked like or that there were 66
miles of streams on Manhattan and 25% of
the island was marshes in one kind or
another most of which were these salt
marshes with this sort of very
structured landscape of mud flats and
then low salt marsh and the high salt
marsh all driven by the tidal elevations
or the seven different kinds of forests
or this is what Time Square my to look
like four hundred years ago a beautiful
then maple swamp home to black bears and
wood ducks or the sandy beaches that the
British headquarters map shows extended
all the way from the tip of Manhattan up
to 42nd Street or the ecosystems that
people make like wigwams
this is a wigwam that my son and I built
at the New York Botanical Gardens many
moons ago he's much much taller now so
and it's you know it's within the human
ecosystems that the story about the
Lenape sort of comes to comes into the
story of ecological story because we
really can't understand how the
landscape was disturbed by by people
what were people doing how more people
living in this landscape unless we talk
about them so let me just tell you a few
words about them that that are on an
Algonquin speaking people they live from
sort of southeastern what we called
southeastern New York down across New
Jersey into eastern Pennsylvania they
they hunted they fished they grew crops
there's a really nice book by William
Penn from the late 17th early 18th
century William Penn knew the Lanai
Lynott bay people as he called them and
he was completely fascinated and a
little bit the Waldron by them he'd say
you know take me to your leader and they
would just laugh like we don't have that
you know we don't have a king of elam
Ave you know
they lived in these sort of small
hunting gathering groups that were
independent but also you know knew each
other and and more or less got along he
would say I want you to sign this piece
of paper this land deed and they would
say what is that you know when we tell
stories we just tell our stories you
know they obviously had a very rich and
and full culture but it was a culture
and oral culture not something about
pieces of paper and it's a sure if you
want to if you want to settle over there
for a little while that's okay that's
fine by us there's lots of room there's
lots of room here they had no idea that
you could you know they had no idea that
this European idea that you could give
away the land and own it forever that
was seemed seemed unconscionable to them
you know something that was outside
their imagination they Dutch people
would say well you know your what about
this sea want these this wampum that's
what gets your money right and they
would say money no that's not money do
you know how long it takes to make one
of those things you know each of those
beads it's comes from a the purple part
of a quad shell a clam shell that we
find on the beach and that requires a
bone all to carve out that and then to
take another all and put the hole
through you know each one of those beads
is hundreds of hours of work this isn't
money this is this is a cultural gift
this doesn't mean I give to mark you to
Mike my respect to you really an
extraordinary culture that that really
collapsed as soon as the the Dutch
showed up in New York and I don't know
if you know William Cronin spark written
here at Yale I'm about the sort of
similar experience of the Connecticut
Indians but um it's a really sad story
there are a lot pay people still some
live in Oklahoma and some live in
Wisconsin and some live in New Jersey
and a few live up in Canada so but to go
back to the life the amazing life they
had on Manhattan you know one of things
they did was they lit fires to manage
the landscape and we can't you know know
this from a map we can only know this by
modeling it by actually using computer
maps that are models of where fire goes
turns out the u.s. Forest Service has a
great model called Farsight that they
use to predict where wildfires go and
you give it these inputs the vegetate
and weather conditions the topography
the ignition points and then you get the
outputs who get fire intensities and
fire frequencies and we wrap this in a
in a spatial model that allowed us to
map where all the fires were for 200
years on Manhattan Island so we could
get a sense of how fire impacted the
ecosystems we wrapped the disturbance
model in what's called a succession
model which is what happens if you burn
it today and then you leave it for five
years or if you leave it for ten years
you leave it for 15 years
what kind of ecosystems do you get we
also know that the Lynott they were
practicing horticulture this is the
traditional three sisters garden of corn
beans and squash a kind of symbiosis
that was invented down in Mesoamerica
and then traded up into North America
they make mounds in the early springtime
and then would plant corn in the top and
then let the corn grow up to be about a
foot high and then they would plant
beans along the edges of the mounds and
you know beans have these modules that
are nitrogen-fixing that have a bacteria
in them that fixes the nitrogen out of
the atmosphere and so the beans were
literally feeding the corn and the roots
of the mound at the same time that the
beans were these climbing beans that
climbed on the on the scaffold of the
corn plants so that's why it's a
symbiosis because each one is giving to
the other and then between the mound
through a plant squash and you know
squash has these big old leaves and it
would help keep the water in and keep
the wat the soil from eroding away and
would also keep the weeds down so I you
know I've grown up a garden like this
for about 15 years now and they're
really productive they're super
productive the great you know corn beans
and squash these are all fruits that you
can collect and gather and dry and the
Cape over the winter time cuz you know
January December do you really want to
go hunting you know you really want to
wade down into the water to get oysters
or clams you know dinner state dinner
plate size oysters and clams know you
know you want to make some succotash of
course this is a kind of disturbance
right and we're Todd you know I'm sure
if we go up the hill to the forestry an
environmental studies tool you'll be
talked about habitat destruction and
deforestation
and this is it you know this is you know
the one off they would have a campsite
and they wouldn't light fires and clear
a field and then after about 25 years 20
25 30 years they would abandon the field
that would become an old field which is
kind of ecosystem type of its own which
then eventually would succeed to a shrub
land which then we succeed to a kind of
forest and what kind of forest would
depend on the slope and that soil type
and the disturbance history and in this
sense this is how we can turn
reconstruct the neighborhoods of
Manhattan the neighborhoods in this
context are our ecosystems but for the
lobby they were just like our ecosystems
of the city today in the same way that
you know we know we can go to Chinatown
and get certain kind of food or then go
on to the Upper East Side and see a
certain kind of people or we can go down
to the theater district can do sorts of
things like each neighborhood has its
own configuration its own kind of people
its own kind of place well that was the
same way that they would interact with
these places it's that that their notion
of what those interactions were of what
their neighbors were wasn't just people
but it was also mushrooms and 600
species of flowering plants and shrubs
and trees 85 different species of fish
freshwater fishes saltwater fishes and a
dramas fishes going back and forth some
350 species of birds about 75 different
species of mammals including beavers I
always like to talk about beavers
because you know beavers and one of the
reasons why the Dutch came right because
they wanted to kill these guys for their
furs and make thanks warm fur hats out
of them
and you know the way the white beavers
make their lives as I think an analogy
for the way we make our lives you know
beavers are sort of hardwired by
evolution then when they hear running
water they want to build a dam right and
why do they want to build a dam well you
know dams allow them to to move their
food source around which are these trees
right they like the inner cambium of the
trees and those are big things so if you
have water it's easier to move them
around to float them over to your Lodge
and your Lodge if it's in the middle of
the pond as a moat right that keeps the
way the wolves and the and
Aires and the other predators that might
eat you so beavers they do this for
their own reasons right of course if
you're a fish living in the stream and
you're a fish that likes running water
and beavers come along you think ah
that's terrible
you guys just destroyed my habitat why
did you do that yeah I can't stand that
but if if you're a fish that likes
slow-moving water is like being a pond
you're like God beavers that's cool
right that's just what I need you know
you just made my habitat thank you very
much of course the beaver didn't think
about it at all
right the people was just doing it for
its own purposes and they often think
that this is this is also a way of
thinking about the way human beings
modify the landscape you know it's not
like you know we put this building here
it's not because we wanted to take away
the forest that was here it's because we
wanted to have a nice place to give
lectures in right that's why we put in
here for people to learn you know we had
a purpose we just didn't sort of think
about what were the environmental
consequences for the other things that
might have wanted that building there
were wolves on Manhattan there were
wolves until the 1720s there were black
bears there was a black bear shot in the
1630s Teddy Roosevelt actually wrote a
history of New York he talks about a
mountain lion the Dutch treat on the
east side of Manhattan in the 1680s
there's another part of the project
where I me and my students we would read
about the plants and the fish and we've
developed species lists and we match up
all this anonomys and eventually come to
this this idea that there were about a
thousand likely species living on
Manhattan not thinking about the insects
just with a vertebrate animals and the
plants and that allowed us to do this
third thing which was to populate the
island so not just study its geography
but actually study its biogeography its
it's biological geography to remember
all these different residents and of
course what connects species to each
other into the environment it's the
notion of habitat and habitat for all
species is the combination of just a few
things food water shelter and
reproductive resources that's habitat so
and that's the game of life you know in
in nature's world if you have enough
food water and shelter so you can grow
up to be an adult and then reapered
and your kids can have enough food water
and shelter to grow up to reproduce then
you've won the game you've won the game
so that's what a habitat is of course
every species has its own life history
its own ways of putting those things
together our idea is that each one of
those things is a map what if you made
the map of what wolves need what to eat
and the map of where they get their
water from and a map of where their
shelter is and a map of their den sites
well the intersection of those Maps
would be the map of where wolves might
be found so that's what we started doing
we started reading habitat descriptions
like you might sign that a field guide
and we started mapping them so you know
a beaver needs a slowly meandering
stream with aspen trees and alders
willows near the water that's the ideal
beaver habitat so we would started
making lists so if I want to know where
beavers are I need to make I would need
a map of the streams I'm out for the
Aspen's a map for the alders and a map
for the Willows and that's good what
about bog Turtles a bog Turtles need
insects and sunny places and other
things wet Meadows and what about
Bobcats will Bobcats need rabbits and
beavers and den sites and you'll notice
you'll notice a couple of things here so
just in this this kind of made up
example you can see that the things
beaver need bog Turtles need and and
Bobcats need don't overlap with each
other most things in nature don't need
the things that somebody else needs
right because if they do you would
compete with them and that's not so good
so you know there's a lot of pressure in
evolution too to separate out the niches
this is another idea that Hutchinson
wrote above about here at Yale but
occasionally there are species that are
on the column here like beavers there's
beavers there and beavers we have them
because Bobcats depend on them but we
also have beavers over here because
beavers are something we're interested
in in their own right and that actually
makes the connection so if you start
playing this game out you're like okay
well if I need to have Aspen for beavers
well what does Aspen need
well Aspen needs website Aspen needs
fire and dry soils
or what is a wet meadow need so what
meadow needs beavers maybe right beavers
make dams and that creates wet Meadows
and maybe some other things what does
the sunny place need and what does a
fire need what does a dry soil need and
so for this part of the project it
became sort of eric going around and
asking all of his friends you know well
what does a beaver need you know you go
talk to your mammalogists friends or
what Aspen's need you go over the
Botanical Garden and ask the the
botanist there you know what is the
fight what does a fire need you know you
talk to a fire ecologist or a soil
scientist it turns out that you know in
a way that's mapping all the different
aspects of the environment and all the
different kinds of scientific
disciplines where those might be found
and when you draw it all out you could
ask her to sparsely fill matrix like
this and in the monocots a case it had
about 1,600 elements going down through
the floor and about 1,600 elements going
out this way through the side of the
building a very large matrix it turns
out that this way of seeing the world is
a is a very important way of configuring
mapping our world today if if this was
Facebook and you you know you and all
your friends on Facebook and you had all
your friends on Facebook and this was
the pattern of the friending that's what
Facebook knows right that's a
multi-billion dollar business model this
is what Google's doing every night you
know Google has these programs are
searching through the web and it
connects it sees how are all the
websites of the world connected to each
other and then it makes you know makes
this network diagram then has a very
fast algorithm for searching through it
so when you type in you know I don't
know you know how to make how to bake
turkey or something what it's doing is
its searching a network diagram like
this and finding the most likely
responses and then bringing that back to
you this is what the government is
trying to figure out about terrorist
networks this is a representation of the
way the power grid is organized this is
the way ecology works and so because of
that there's all these kind of different
scholars and disciplines in mathematics
and computer scientists and sociologists
and ecologists that are working
how do we visualize and see these
networks and so we were able to pick up
some of the tools to map these it's
actually map that what we call the mere
web of Manhattan the manihot Tamir wood
so this is a little detail of that mere
web each of those different points is a
different plant or animal type or a
different stream type for a different
soil type and each of those gray lines
is a different habitat connection
between that thing and some other things
some other element in the mere web each
documented in our in our database right
so very specific but you can see when
you do them all that you get this very
dense network of interactions this is
what makes nature strong this is what
makes nature resilient if you take out
one node the whole thing doesn't
collapse because there's so many cross
linkages that allow it any one thing to
get to find some other way for it to
survive something else that's important
about this is that one of these nodes
that's up here up here just behind me is
the lamothe a node is the human node
right which is an important node it has
a lot of connections through fire and
through horticulture and through fishing
and through hunting it's an important
node but it's not the only node for the
first in the first business and the
second is that that node also depends on
other nodes right those people aren't
independently living there and affecting
other things they're also dependent on
all the other ones one of the things
that's wonderful about these network
diagrams is that you can sort of see the
world through the perspective of any one
node and what it's connected to and what
those things are connected to or you can
sort of zoom out and see it from this
perspective this is if we zoom out and
see the whole mere web that middle ball
there that's the terrestrial plants and
animals and abiotic elements the the
things on land because we're talking
about an island that sort of shoulder
that cluster over there on the on the
left side that's the freshwater elements
the things in the streams and the
wetlands and the freshwater marshes and
then this cluster over here that's sort
of off by itself that's the marine
elements in the way that the sea is kind
of its own just
a compartment in the network and yet
there are connections that bring it back
so we call these things mere webs after
John Muir because John Muir said when we
try and pick out anything by itself we
find that it's bound fast by a thousand
invisible cords that cannot be broken to
everything in the universe and this is
the idea that's at the heart of
conservation to identify those networks
those cord to make some fewer them
visible and then to make sure that the
most important ones last so that the
whole system can last the mere webs also
allowed us to go back to the spatial
domain to the map domain so we wrote
algorithms programs that reach into the
GIS the read the network and say ok well
for beavers I need the map of the
streams
I need the map of the alders I need the
map to be Aspen and I'm going to combine
them all together and I'm going to make
the map of the Beavers which is the
bottom right-hand panel over there and
then because all of those maps are based
on top of based on that British
headquarters map and that British
headquarters map is geo reference to the
modern city it means that we can make
the map where beavers might have been
400 years ago in the modern blocks of
the city so and this is the website that
the Priya kindly mentioned at the
beginning we Licio org
backslash explore gives you a sort of
Explorer where you can zoom in to
Manhattan and click on any block and get
a list of all the plants and animals
that might have lived in that block
mammals and the birds the reptiles and
the amphibians and the fish and the
plants and their probabilities there's
links about their conservation status we
show a picture of the kind of ecosystem
that might have lived in that block and
you know we can we can watch people
using the website you know by looking at
the web statistics you know and like
Google Analytics you can actually see
people spending hours just going block
by block by block you know because they
can go you know the first thing anybody
does is go to their block right the
block where they live or the place where
they work and they see what was there
and then they're like oh I wonder
what was on the next block well the next
block and of course they know if you
walk along the street wets buildings
buildings its buildings its buildings
right but if you do it on the wiki
website it's you know forest it's a
slightly different for its it's a
slightly different ports oh it's a salt
marsh and that's something all the
species change right because now you're
in a completely different ecosystem yeah
it's really great it's really trying to
like give people it's sort of visceral
sense of biodiversity in the geographies
that they know you know to say that on
that block you know on 61st to 60s 62nd
Street between Park and Madison used to
be you know 500 species that I'm going
to lived in that block and now there's
you know people dogs cats little sparrow
pigeon you know it's not trying to say
one is good or one's bad but just trying
to put them in opposition to each other
in a in a kind of vital way that this
kind of mapping can do so I was very
lucky in the course of the project to to
meet my friend mark Boyer who had a
background in sort of digital
photography and design and he
volunteered for with me for five years
to take the data that we were building
for mannahatta and reconstructing what
third Avenue for example look like four
hundred years ago so I would give mark
the topography and then we would fill in
the water and give it some illumination
and shaped the landscape and then the
map of the different ecosystems which is
that ecological landscape that landscape
mosaic and then fill those ecosystem
with little 3d models of all of the
plants and animals might have lived in
them and that allows us to make these
kind of images and they're there like
what you see you know an avatar or Lord
of the Rings or something right some
made-up movie landscape but this is
Times Square looking out to the west on
September 12 1609 right this is a
particular perspective we can literally
take a picture out of any window in
Manhattan and reconstruct what that view
would it look like so we can you know
paddle up the East River like a know
load up a dugout canoe and see murray
hill there
and see that the water coming down at
Turtle Bay
you know what the UN is we can fly like
a bird on the fall migration you know we
get these kettles of Hawks to fly down
the Hudson River and so that's not a hot
time the left and New Jersey over here
on the right there's that beach at 125th
Street I mentioned before and sort of
understand how mannahatta is a place
that fits into a larger landscape the
landscape of the Hudson River estuary in
the Mantic ocean and on the east coast
of North America or we might even
imagine Henry Hudson right so what
happened on September 13th he sails up
the river a little bit he Moors
this is an image sort of imagining the
Sun rising that warning
there's hence hudson ship maybe a 42nd
Street in the Hudson River named the
river named after him and I'd love to
think about Henry Hudson because you
know Hudson
he didn't mean to found New York right
he didn't mean to do any of that Hudson
had one idea in his mind and that idea
was to get to China to trade with China
to find in the northeast passageway and
he was sure he's gonna find it I mean
that's why you know he eventually died
and had some riverbay because he got or
Hudson Bay because he got in there and
couldn't get out so you know he saw the
Hudson River and he got a glimpse of how
you know the Hudson opens up in the
Tappan Zee he thought aha this is it
this is the fjord to China I just go a
little bit farther China and he got to
Albany and had to turn around very
disappointing for him but you know I
think what's what's what's ironic about
Hudson is that there was something so
precious right in front of him that he
couldn't see and that was mana hata
right that was the mere web that was
this like incredible example of nature
with all of its parts all the species
interacting with each other including
with people in a way that could last for
thousands of years something we don't
have anywhere in the world today nowhere
in the world do we have this so so
precious so valuable and he completely
missed it and we live in a world where
we have lots of things from China right
we don't have this anymore
the same kind of mapping
the same kind of visualization we can
allow us to to see the landscapes where
we live in a completely new way to go
down to that collect pond and lower
Manhattan see the smoke rising from the
lop a settlement see the fields and the
shrublands and the forests see the salt
marshes and seven different kinds of
forests and the beaches and the Hudson
River and to see that in that geography
of the city today because of course it's
changed right yeah and it's changed you
know much as Hudson had a value had a
vision had a a thing he really wanted to
do this world is the reflection of all
the dreams the people have had living in
New York City and the 400 years since
right some of which were frustrated some
which were accomplished some of which
built on others some of which struck out
in new directions but this landscape
this configuration of ecosystems is what
the past generations have left us
through the act of imagining what they
want in New York City to be so that
leads to this fifth and final act which
is about how do we imagine the features
to come for our city and one I want to
suggest that it comes in part from
seeing our lives in this long-term
relationship with place it's not just
about us but about our parents and our
grandparents and our great-grandparents
and it's gonna be about our kids and our
grandkids and my great-grandkids we have
to see how we're going to live here over
long generations over seven generations
like that like the Madonna shawnee
talked about and not that one of these
is better than the other but they have
to learn from each other that I've
really come to believe that the only way
cities will survive in the long term is
by taking the lessons that nature gives
and building them into the city into the
way we construct the city and at the
same time I think the only way that
nature what nature we have left will
survive is by talking about and helping
people in cities see the value and the
importance of nature for their lives to
actually see cities as a kind of habitat
for people where they separate food and
they supply water and they supply
shelter and reproductive resources
you're thinking about that
education for our kids and they do this
fifth thing that arguably has been why
city has been built forever and in the
first place which is provide a sense of
meaning that place where where new ideas
can happen where we can dream we can
talk to each other or we can make
fortunes or we could lose fortunes you
know this sense where we you know build
faith and religion and government you
know cities are at the root of all these
things that we call civilization and I
think what's so exciting about this time
in in New York City and in other cities
around the world is people are finding
that they can find meaning not just in
you know in the church or in science or
in art or in you know making a lot of
money but they can also find it in the
way they cut their food comes from and
whether water comes from what kind of
building they live in and how they treat
their kids so at the end of mannahatta I
worked with them an artist Heidi Heidi
Neilson where we took images of the city
as it was in 2008 and then we tried to
imagine what the future of those
landscapes might look like you know so
Madison Square with streetcars instead
of cars and streams instead of storm
drains and and red oak forest rather
than London plane trees we're not trying
to imagine the city without architecture
without people actually trying to
imagine a way of living in urban life
that she works in that place and that
scales to scale up all of the Upper East
Side with green roofs on every roof and
with a stream coming out of the
reservoir and around the Metropolitan
Museum of Art and winding down to the
East River or even to imagine over some
long period of time a redistribution of
of where people live and how we live in
this landscape it turns out that when we
look at satellite images like this like
you could see on Google Maps but the
density of people living on Manhattan is
sixty five thousand people per square
mile it's by far the densest place in
the United States it's it's actually
what gives Manhattan you know that magic
that magic of so many people in such a
tight confined space you know it's
frustrating but it's also you know
exhilarating but if you go out to New
Jersey or even parts of the Bronx or
around in Queens you'll find communities
there's a thousand people per square
you know sixty five times less so Heidi
and I thought well what if what if we
grouped everybody at Manhattan density
well then they would only use up 38% of
the area and that means you could have
farm fields again could have wildlife
refuges again even the water could come
up a meter of sea level rises we have
here and people could live I'm not
saying this is what we should do or this
is the advisable thing to do but this is
the kind of thing that comes from
thinking about the city as a landscape
as a mapped landscape of ecosystems that
can be arranged in a whole variety of
different ways and I think we were so
thrilled about this and the kind of
responses to this the people really
wanted to talk about these kind of maps
that then we went on to build an
application called vision maker which
allows anybody to do this anybody to
play this game it's free its online it's
a tool for what we think of as
ecological democracy this idea that
we're all have something to say about
the place we live and the only way we
actually create better ecologies is if
we have a way to talk to each other so
vision maker sort of combines the
science and the sort of experience of
invention and creativity that we see
like kids playing Minecraft that's a
Minecraft brick and then sharing this
idea of using the computer to share
ideas so vision maker allows you to see
the historical ecology of the city to
see the current ecology and then to make
your own vision of the future ecology by
changing the ecosystems rearranging them
creating new ones by changing the
lifestyle the people who live in your
city and by playing with the climate
scenarios about the future you know do
we imagine the future of the city this
year 2050 2075 2100 what are we thinking
and then see how the ecology would
change in terms of what it means for the
water water cycle the carbon cycle of
biodiversity and population so I'll just
close by showing you a few screenshots
of the actual application I invite you
to go home tonight and try it out so
clearly free you just have to make a
brief account so this is a map of the
ecosystems of New York City today this
is a first draft of the maps of them
four hundred years ago you can zoom in
say two
park in Brooklyn you can see that those
ecosystems on top of the historical
ecology for your neighborhood we have
these tools allow you to paint the
ecosystems we have this sort of idea of
the raster painting where you get to
actually change the ecosystems you can
choose the lifestyle the people that
live in your idea of the future we have
five lifestyles we have a average New
Yorker lifestyle we have an average
American lifestyle we have an average
earthly and lifestyle we have a monopoly
lifestyle and we have what we call it
eco hipster or eco conscious so that we
like all the students here at Yale right
you know that's you know people eat
vegetables people that ride their bikes
people that um that live in a little bit
denser space oh and most importantly
that all the eco hipsters they choose to
get their electricity from renewable
sources which any New Yorker can do just
by signing up with con Edison and that
does dramatic things your carbon cycle
by the way anyway so only we have five
climates in there or six climate
scenarios and then what happens is the
model runs and it compares you over
vision in terms of water carbon
biodiversity population and we're
playing around some economic stuff now
in terms of what that landscape will
look like in 1609 and today and your
vision going into the future and then if
you like your vision you can share it
with everybody else
so this isn't the end-all be-all and
there's a lot of things that have to be
made better about this but it's it's
trying to like use you know the power of
the internet the power of technology the
power of all the things we understand
about ecology to map a better future and
not for just you know me to say or a
professor to say but actually for each
and every one of us to take the
responsibility to create that future
together so that all of us can live
together the skeptical the intrepid the
imaginative and the tree into the
long-term future of New York City thank
you very much
sure thank you so much for an absolutely
wonderful talk where you've tried to
show each of us the responsibility sense
of responsibility we have so we open up
to questions now thank you very much
Priya also very happy to hear critiques
and comments and what did we miss what
can we do better just a drink of water
thanks very much I may have just missed
this in the talk but I you you got the
typography from the British map and then
you visited sites with the same sort of
of habitat types to get the species
lists yeah but how did you place the
ecological communities you know this was
a maple forest and this was a hemlock to
their location on Manhattan yep New York
State there's an ecologic community
guide that comes from the New York State
Heritage Program so there's a
classification of ecosystems for though
for the whole state and each one of
those describes you know what are the
kind of conditions that that ecosystem
depends upon where would you find us a
high salt marsh for example so we
basically encode that into you know as a
rule based algorithm that says you know
this is kind of ecosystems you hards
this sort of tidal level or this sort of
slow by this sort of soil type and then
we use the mere went to map the
ecosystems so when the maps are actually
probability maps it's the problem you
know the probability in this ten meter
cell that this ecosystem might have been
there so clumping there clearly for some
cells you might have you know multiple
probabilities for different ecosystem
types right because that's the way
nature works and then you know the thing
we don't really you know then we can't
know for sure I mean we can get an idea
about the geology and the topography and
things from the old maps from the
historic maps and and modern studies but
the disturbance is the hard thing right
so that's what we use models to sort of
scope out what is there to the range of
potential effects of lighting fires or a
four to culture I'm wondering if it had
any impact on sort of political
I guess planning for city planning yeah
yeah so I think um I think we don't know
yet you know I'm kind of playing the
long game as you can tell another 400
year game so you know I think in that
sense it's been effective that the
people talk about it all the time I
don't think it's I think it's hard for
people living in Manhattan if they've if
they've learned about mana Haughton not
see not have this reference idea in
their back of their minds does the parks
department use the tools oh yeah of
course
yeah yeah yeah yeah and you know I I
compared our list of ecosystems with the
set of ecosystems we have in the city
right and we talk about what are we
missing and then what have we lost
there's also you know what really
brought it home though is it was
hurricane sandy because if you you know
I don't I don't have it with me in this
PowerPoint but if you if you compare the
the map of where the former salt marshes
are and the areas that flooded in the
city it's like a 90% overlap of the two
and that's very clear and and then you
know it's funny like the number one
response I would get from people when I
would show that to them is oh that makes
sense
and I was like well if it makes sense
then why why did you allow your house to
get built there right you know why did
the city allow that which is exactly
what the conversation is now right about
what's what New York City should do
about sea level rise and climate change
you know the thing is that most of those
you know most of us didn't build our
individual houses most of us bought a
house from somebody else that was built
there sometime in the past right and in
some cases like in lower Manhattan it
was 300 years ago or 350 years ago that
that landfill happened and now you know
and then somebody built a low house and
somebody toward that debtor built a
bigger house and and now we have a
skyscraper there that's a problem like
what do you do now it's not not you know
it's obvious to see the problem in light
of historical ecology it's another thing
to let you think about what is the
proactive solution and when in fact I
think New York City is trying but it's
so hard to balance all the things
after pellets that they really not made
a lot of success in making the city more
resilient in terms of the next next
hurricane thank you very much I really
enjoyed it and I'm wondering with the
vision maker app and mapping if there's
any you just use the word proactive
which is that I was gonna use tips or
suggestions for people to how to reach
their vision so like ways to lower your
carbon footprint or things you can do to
keep nature bring back maybe nature into
the neighborhood are those integrated or
will they be there there's a little bit
of advice but I'm sure we can do a lot
more about that we one of the
functionalities we built out
particularly thinking about schools but
it's been used in other contexts too is
this there's a kind of challenge
functionality where somebody can pick an
area of the city and then set goals like
you know I want to get up I want to
reduce greenhouse gas emissions 80% by
2050 which is our climate change goal I
want to you know increase the pervious
cover by 10% that sort of thing and then
you know people can make different
visions that meet that goal right
because there's as you as you suggest
different pathways to that we did one we
we had a kind of mapping what would you
call it like a sort of map arama at the
zoo where we had middle school kids all
over the city create visions and then
bring them together to talk about them
and the goal was the around the 8050
goal and this one kid gets up and he's
like this is just impossible you just
can't do it
just can't do it and then one of the
other kids said did you did you change
the lifestyle really important to change
the lifestyle you know you know in
science often you know I think in
science we often feel like you know we
need to figure it out and then tell
people what the right solution is vision
makers a little bit the opposite which
is sort of create the platform and then
let people play to discover what the
solution is maybe with a little bit of
advice here suggest so to what to what
extent are the historical ecological
communities and ecosystems of Manhattan
represented in the city's parks today or
the parks any anything like inaccurate
station of what was there or is it
something completely unique and novel
well it varies a lot although it's
surprising how many natural errors there
are left in New York City I'm involved
on the with an organization called the
natural areas Conservancy which is an
organization dedicated to the ten
thousand acres of natural areas in the
city parks these are the areas that like
hit the park maps from the 1960s are
like not yet developed know the place
where they haven't had enough money yet
to build the baseball field or the
basketball court or whatever it is you
know but now their forests are their
wetland and they're valuable to us so
they did an ecological assessment of all
the natural areas in the city three
years ago and then they mapped it
against the Heritage Program once
ecological communities and I think I
think don't hold me to the exactly look
though it was about 35 the different
ecosystems including a few novel
ecosystems that are not in the
classification system so so our arum and
that was citywide Manhattan had about 54
communities we think our wait licking
and mapping is coming around coming in
closer to 130 different types well Wow
okay so you know it's a little biased I
live in the Bronx
I live on City Island and there's a
beautiful park Pelham Bay Park
that's right beside to the island it's
three times the size of Central Park as
a wildlife sanctuary in it and if you go
out to Hunter and twin islands you'll
feel like you're in Maine but you're in
the Bronx it's really fantastically
beautiful big trees rocks sparkling
waters lots of wildlife
attributed to the new expanded use of
the ubers and the lifts in Manhattan I
didn't hear that statistic but I would
attribute it to the Clean Air Act are
you selling this book at Barnes & Noble
here uh well I'm not personally but
Barnes Noble how far is fair enough and
are you doing this in conjunction with
the Botanical Garden program that they
have parents yeah
yes no but I'd be happy to come and talk
to them I think you should do the
presentation over there and with the FE
Film Festival oh thank you take that as
an invitation thank you again for the
talk so I think when thinking about maps
and environment with the past of the
present in the future um that past
vision can be dramatically different
depending on what your baseline is and I
think like it's really fascinating to
hear about all the the information and
the maps in the history we have of this
Henry Hudson September day and that
being this theme and this baseline is
cool but I wonder you know looking at
the vision maker maps how different that
would look like if we looked at a
baseline prior to that or maybe
somewhere in the middle of the 1800s and
certainly it would take a lot of effort
on your projects part to create fully
formed baselines for other years for
your part but I have you heard that
being like a dialogue if it's happening
with people who have interacted with the
tool or people that you've worked with
about maybe the difference if that Henry
Hudson day wasn't the baseline this
project used sure sure so I think
there's a couple couple threads you're
pulling on there so so of course you
know any moment in history could be the
baseline right there's nothing you know
there's nothing magical about 1609
except that that's the moment that
people been imagining for four hundred
years
right so if you you know you've if you
read The Great Gatsby that close
what you know him imagining that moment
right there's all you know there's all
these 19th century kind of romantic
paintings on that moment and you know
one can argue that that's a really
important historical moment right
because that's what we use shifted
cultures it's also hugely important to
collage achill moment right because
that's when Europeans come and they
bring their pigs and their domesticated
animals and domesticated plants that's
where they start messing around full-on
up a and a lot they start do it stop
doing their things so so the reason we
picked it is you know just like when
you're writing to history you can't
write about everything that happened
through history you have to pick a time
just like when you make a map you can't
map everything in the world you have to
pick into the map we picked it for a
particular reason and that's a
conservation reason is they want people
it's when they imagine New York City to
remember these images for it to be like
seared on their minds in a way that they
will never forget because they want
people to remember that that is that is
the truth you know that is the sort of
the ecological truth of our place that's
why we can live there is because of this
of this amazing amazing ecology that was
there and that's what we need to recover
everywhere in the world right that's the
whole conservation purpose so yeah so so
sir
whenever I talk about we licky I show
like the shoreline you know during the
height of the glaciation and it was 120
meters or 120 meters lower and 100 miles
offshore and I talked about how the
shoreline came in it's a way of sort of
you know we only have to deal with a
meter of sea level rise the landscape
dealt with 120 meters already you know
that kind of thing I mean you can tell
this from the stories but yeah that's
why we picked the 1609
thank you so much I've been so excited
what listening to everything you've been
opening up to me today thank you and in
doing so I was thinking one thing you
mentioned how we New Yorkers don't look
back and then the incredible photographs
you're showing me of how you could show
me what it looked like in 1673 or 1812
and that is so exciting and I think of
downtown Manhattan
yeah great grid and every grid has one
intersection with and they all have
posts and I could just vision at least
like 11 by 17 or you know a picture of
that you know protected from the
elements and on each block on each
intersection of the crane just the
picture in like the date yeah and as
people have walked through the city they
tons of people walking through the city
they see that photograph and go oh yeah
they would just be exciting and it would
start to let them think about where they
really are right would you see that be a
possibility yeah I'm very wealthy you
know you'd only be like that well yeah I
mean so so I mean one of the one of the
great things I think to bring back to
the theme is instead of imagine these is
just you know one map but imagine them
as you know this sort of soul set of
data resources right that are expressed
in space and so I'll just give you an
idea of some of the you know kind of
more artistic things that people have
done you know taking up here theme so
two years ago I was contacted by this by
this guy a student from this school of
visual visual arts SVA downtown and he
was working with somebody of the Cornell
Laboratory of Ornithology and they were
picking a few points in Manhattan like
the clock pond and a place on the High
Line and they were looking at our
distribution data and then matching it
with sounds from their archive of those
species and then doing it in a 360 kind
of way so if you face this way you would
hear those kind of birds and those kind
of wildlife if you heard this way you
would hear the ocean and now you would
hear the Hudson River you know it was
really beautiful and we
and they took me out and you know you
can put these these very high-end
earphones on and it was so it was so
amazing like so dramatic like so much so
that I remember standing on the High
Line and like looking out down 10th
Avenue right that amazing view and then
hearing the sounds of 400 years ago and
almost feeling sick to my stomach
because of the cognitive dissonance of
the - right we've talked about like
local radio stations that you would tune
into as you you know go around the city
and that the sound changes as you go
around people have talked about the this
just kind of the visualization we we
tried to get the MTA to loan us some of
the bus shelters this is you know back
in 2009 that was when they're first
putting on those the beautiful glass
bless shelters now and you know those
aren't specific places so we said well
you know if you can't sell the
advertising commute let us have it and
then we'll make an image at that place
you know so you don't see it walking
down the street so you know this sort of
thing or I'm I want to talk to this
designer and he had this idea of like
writing on the circle line tour and
there would be a large screen TV as the
boat went around it would be showing you
what that would look like you know just
on the TVs you can't like look around
and like that there's all kinds of
wonderful things to be done I think with
with this kind of information thank you
so much for the talk um so this work
you're doing with mannahatta
and sort of like this is establishing
like a reference ecosystem for all of
that I'm wondering how that goes into
conversation with other work you've done
in like novel ecosystems which are sort
of essentially a historical and when you
look at sort of conservation a place
like this how do you see those two
things interact yeah yeah yeah so that I
don't know if you know but then the
notion of a novel ecosystem is an
ecosystem that people have made and
they've changed it so much that it's it
probably can't go back to where it you
know what it used to be and many urban
ecosystems are sort of in this they were
just required like just a ginormous
amount of effort in order to put it back
where it is so I mean I in my own mind
there's a couple different avenues so
what one is well that's why you got to
conserve the places for they are right
you know that's why conservation of wild
places is so important and wildness
that's sort of every scale whether
that's the natural area in a city park
core you know thick wilderness area in
Canada in the Amazon or something right
that's that's part of the answer another
thing is that you know I think urban
ecosystems are just as important for
their connection to people as they are
for the ecosystem services they provide
that sort of thing so you know like we
know that you know children respond
strongly just being the outside and
nature having sort of unstructured play
in nature doesn't have to have the exact
species composition for that to work
right you know I think we need to think
about conservation is this sort of
dialogue between conserving the things
about nature that we want to conserve
but also conserving the human
relationship to that nature and so you
know any place can serve a role in that
you know not everybody has to do the
same sort of thing so that's the way I
think about it and then and then a lot
of my work today is thinking about long
term futures for the for the planet like
what does the planet gonna look like in
2100 you know when the demographic
transition is complete when 80% of
people live in towns and cities around
the world when extreme poverty has been
eradicated you know that's gonna be
completely different world for
conservation and that might be the time
where we go back and start to think
about what we can do for those novel
ecosystems I one thing that sort of
troubled me about your presentation was
the early on you referred to the Lenni
Lenape as collapsing it felt a bit
agentless as if it wasn't the Dutch who
basically caused them to collapse so
with that in mind I'm wondering whether
whether you engage with or whether
there's not a way to engage with in the
forward thinking work with a more agent
full view of climate change that this is
happening because there are people
causing it I mean as your book showed
after oil and cars and some of these are
not accidents or magic and I know that's
a bit of the lifestyle angle that you
brought in but feel like there's there
still is more of an agency to be brought
in for something like corporations like
introducing children to the idea that
there are people doing this right right
so I didn't mean to suggest that the
will not be collapsed on their own
that was inevitable that was just me
being brief I think that larger scheme
of things so I can talk a little more
about that so you know the way the way
you know when we understand is there
were people in the New York City region
for 8,000 years there wasn't the loan ah
pay the whole eight thousand years right
there probably many many different
cultures we don't know exactly when the
lanata culture sort of form maybe about
a thousand years ago near the sort of
middle to late woodland period so so
let's say a thousand years alone ah
people living there and you know doing
the kind of activities I talked about
but actually arguably increasing the
biodiversity of the land again not
pointed purposefully probably but but
through creating new ecosystems right
actually creating meadows and creating
old field - that sort of thing and and
modifying the forest structure through
the use of fire and those kind of tools
so you know what happens when the Dutch
arrive is is a really fascinating
cultural story because you know what
they wanted was specific resources right
like like beaver skins beaver pelts and
so what would they get for that you know
they would give things that will not be
didn't have like a hatchet or a blanket
or alcohol these sort of things and what
that meant was you know before before
that kind of market sort of economy is
there the manape you know but there
would be no purpose to kill a lot of
beavers right somebody gonna do with a
lot of Beaver skins right but once that
happens Wow so and and the consequence
of that is if you if you don't need to
if you don't have a way of like
acquiring wealth and sort of infinite
kind of way right and you're living a
lifestyle where you move three or four
times a year if you know like you know
Kelly you don't have any you know
domesticated animals to carry stuff for
you you got to carry everything you own
what you actually want to carry with you
is the respect of your community right
so if you're an old guy like me living a
little mopping community the ideal thing
would have been you did right by your
neighbors all the way up and you know so
that they respected you you know when
you're an older person when the Dutch
get there and they say I want as many
papers as you can get me in I'm gonna
give you this cool hatch into this pot
you know what that gave and this is what
Cronan writes about is that gave a lot
of power to the young people right right
and it sort of I met you know turned
over that relationship so that weakened
them that Dutch brought domesticated
animals
eggs we know that there was a lot of
conflict around pigs because the pigs
would run into the Lenape corn gardens
you know very destructive they didn't
like that they would kill the pigs and
Duchin like that there was a kind of
nasty guy named William Venky in 1642
that came in and had sort of a iron iron
idea about in a Dutch sovereignty and so
he started a war basically which was a
ran for 20 years and terrible terrible
atrocities on either side and and the
ultimate was that the law not bei pled
to Anna parts of Brooklyn and Queens
from Manhattan and down into New Jersey
and Staten Island and then eventually
they lost their land there etcetera
etcetera etcetera and then you know
there's their story is similar to many
many Native American stories you know in
the US history
it's just they lost really early yeah
which is why I wanted to emphasize that
they're not gone they're still here but
they're also a difficult community now
to interact with because there's you
know still have these sort of long-term
fracturing so you know I've met with and
talked to them but we know there are two
lopping nations in Oklahoma that don't
get along with each other there there's
some recognize people and Wisconsin and
up in Canada and First Nations but
there's some unrecognized groups they
have a lot of difficulties it's a it's a
really problematic history ask a
question yeah I was just wondering is
there a way to visualize how
dramatically humans have been able to
impact and transform this one template
ecosystem just as a way for sort of
advocacy for climate change given that
we still have people who seem to not
believe in the human generated
activities distorting the pace right
right yeah I guess the question of the
whole shtick with from on a hot day is
just to create these juxtapositions
right and not actually not to fill in
but too much commentary about why it
happened but actually say it was this
this now you know that does a couple of
things for you and one it suggests that
it's not just one you know I think most
people live in the city and they just
see the city as it is what it was when
they came there and then that's what
they think it should be in the future
right but if you've just
- then it suggests some some sort of
continuity or some sort of transition
you know it's just there's a third thing
right and then just show such a dramatic
change I think I think also helps right
and and you know and then the way I talk
about it is is seriously not like one is
Nestle better than the other I mean I
love New York City as it is today and I
would have loved Mona hata and I think
we need to find a way for the world be
big enough to have both great cities and
great nature is very curious in sort of
the newer web visualization yeah if some
nodes start pulling too hard we can you
see that visually somehow because I
think we're all you know all of us
scientists and I guess most of the
population is quite stunned at how our
agency has not been understood yeah
appears to not be understood by a lot of
people in power yeah we don't know how
powerful we are doing right yeah yeah
but also I think you know I mean what's
I think what's so interesting about our
time is that we are we've never been as
smart we've never had as much knowledge
information as we have today time for
maybe tomorrow right all the papers that
all the professors are writing now you
know for tomorrow but um and you know
somehow we still don't have the wisdom
to act on that right you know and you
know in New York City I think it's it's
really the sea level rise and the storm
surge is where this is really coming to
bear like it's pretty clear from you
know an objective as far as an objective
scientific perspective that some places
are gonna have to move and or be
redesigned entirely but how you work
that out in the social systems that's
that's what we're trying to figure out
well let's hope that the vision help
social system
take the right sorts of decisions for
the coming 1,500 years thank you so
thank you
[Music]